sailing to Byzantium that is no country
for old men the yang in one another's
arms birds in the trees those dying
generations at their sang the Salmon
Falls the macro crowded seas fish flesh
a foul commend all summer long
whatever is begotten burn and dies
caught in that sensual music all neglect
monuments of an agent left
an agent machinist better poultry sang a
tattered coat upon a stick in less Soul
Clap its hands and sing and louder sing
for every tattered in its metal dress
nor is there singing school but studying
monuments of its own magnificence and
therefore I have sailed the seas and
come to the holy city of Byzantium
Oh soldiers standing and God's holy fire
as in the gold mosaic of Allah come from
the holy fire burning of Jireh and be
the singing masters of my soul consume
my head away sick with desire and
fastened to a dying animal it knows not
what it is and gathering into the
artifice of eternity once out of nature
i shall never take my badly fare from
any natural thing but such a fare
masturbation bladesmiths name of
hammered gold and gold and hammering to
keep the drowsy emperor away or set down
a Golden Bell to sing to lords and
ladies of Byzantium I've read his past
or passing or to come
[Music]
you